good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a blessed day I know we are
because we are now the furthest away we
will ever be this year from Yom Kippur
2020. three we're done you're done we're
done it was it was a rough day yesterday
it was where your fast ranks compared to
all your other fasts but for me this was
absolutely the hardest one yet probably
because I had to I woke up at 7 30 with
rolled and I didn't really get to nap
and the night before I had a migraine
and then I went to sleep and I woke up
feeling better but then the events of
the day no water no coffee no food gave
me another migraine I had a migraine for
24 hours and it was miserable for me
shockingly the most difficult part of
yesterday was not the lack of food it
was the lack of phone I don't talk I
don't think I've ever had a more
difficult time spending the whole day
off of my phone I felt so disconnected I
was ill-prepared I was just shook I've
never had an easier time being off my
phone usually I weirded out by how much
I miss it on yum I'm like wow okay maybe
I have a phone addiction I barely even
noticed yesterday which was so
unexpected but good that means that my
addiction is dissipating I'm sorry not
me
we all have our struggles I was not okay
I'm sorry and if you could count the
amount of times I thought about like
picking out my phone and being like Oh
No it must have been 42 000. that's
crazy does that make you want to make
any changes no no yeah it makes me want
to convert so I never have to do it
again
uh well okay well at least now you're
back with your phone reunited and it
feels so good I love you [ __ ] I'm sorry
I left you alone for 24 hours I hope you
were okay
You Don't Know What You Got Till It's
Gone so true I'm so glad that's behind
us to our Jewish toasters you did it we
did it and we don't have to do it again
for another year so now I can breathe
and actually I felt like it was a really
productive day in terms of atoning I
felt very tone full
um and I feel really good about kicking
off this this new year with positive
energy and happy Vibes and I'm so
looking forward to now getting back to
talking [ __ ] without feeling guilty like
it was not working for me tabulary so
what are you going to do in this new
year
be mindful of that you've been doing in
the past that you needed to atone for
like nothing no I'm totally kidding
um
I think I don't really it wasn't like
specific things you know it was just
like a general being yeah that makes
sense
yeah you know
yeah
it's not like you know I want to you
know commit less crimes you know like I
don't really have specifically do you
feel like you want to talk less [ __ ]
no because
I like it
I like the beat I actually don't even
think we talk that much [ __ ]
like we don't just talk [ __ ] for shit's
sake but we
no I definitely think we talk a lot of
[ __ ] on the show no no I think on the
show we're like super
like good I agree okay I was talking
about on the show in our personal lives
like on FaceTime like we are animals
that's true okay let me ask you a
question is it talking [ __ ] if you're
spitting facts and merely exchanging
information no I don't think that's
considered gossip I I think gossip is
like opinions but if you're just like
stating a fact an unfortunate hurtful
fact yeah I think gossip is like
spreading rumors not exchanging
information not exchanging information
and telling the truth and the truth only
you know I always have a hard time
deciphering like truly and I mean this
generally like what is like gossip and
what is just facts because like okay
let's say someone we know is getting
divorced and like it's like they're not
hiding it like they're getting divorced
but like I tell my friend who doesn't
know I'm exchanging information but I'm
also gossiping I think just telling
someone the information is fine it's
like how you say it and then what you
follow it up with like good she deserves
it she's a cheating [ __ ] right right
the gossip that's why would she be the
cheating [ __ ]
um because she's your friend okay
also by the way today's like a huge
significant day at the toast do you know
why
no
no clue
um because of our guest interview today
well yes which we'll get to in a minute
but no I do believe this is the first
time in toast her story that I am
wearing my hair up aside from that day
last week
did I wear my hair up last week yeah and
it was so stunning when you wore the
1989 sweatshirt
I'm not okay no but I didn't notice when
we logged on today that your hair is up
you're looking dirty I've been trying to
tell you for years that you should put
your hair up and I'm glad that you're on
the hair up train I don't know if I'm
necessarily on the train well I'll have
to watch twice in two weeks so I have to
watch today's episode with a fine tooth
comb the only thing I'll say is that
with the headphones it changes you know
now you kind of look like Princess Leia
you're so [ __ ] mean
you're so [ __ ] mean because it's the
two balls I get it okay now I'm
self-conscious so thank you so much you
look great I just said you look great
but you only hear the negative you want
to hear something funny how you're
wearing your hair down and you look like
Princess Leia [ __ ] that's because I'm
saying the headphones like make us look
like Princess Leia well maybe we should
ditch your headphones okay I know I was
actually thinking about going back to
pods they're just so ugly I know these
at least they're like cool podcast
things but thank you for reminding that
today's episode is gonna be so long and
so special because not only do we have a
fabulous show with the Beverly Hills
finale recap the Salt Lake City recap
fabulous Fast Five two Fabulous Girls we
also have a fabulous interview if you're
listening as a podcast you can just keep
listening it'll be at the end of the
episode and if you're watching on
YouTube but we have another video on our
Channel right now what we did record the
interview uh for video as well we sat
down with Jessica Knoll who is
definitely a role model of ours she is
the author of luckiest girl alive and
she was an executive producer and
screenwriter for the film that just
debuted on Netflix starring Mila Kunis
and it was really cool to talk to an
author like I felt so Scholastic so
Scholastic to talk to an author about
are truly our favorite book and that's
now been turned into a movie She's also
so telling us about her new book which
sounds so good it was just a great
conversation and I'm loving being such a
core part of the literary World well oh
two things one she did tell us
afterwards and I kind of wish we got it
on the recording that um during the
filming Mila Kunis's understudy came up
to her and was like I'm trying to find
the book but it's sold out on Amazon
because they talked about your book on
the toes and they keep talking about it
and we literally sold out a book not
mine happy for her but whatever
um that was really cool and the second
thing
I have such breaking news like breaking
breaking news
do I know it yet no you're gonna be
shocked share with the class
do you know what Ben did yesterday
no he read he read what did he read
he read
um Phil Knight the founder of Nike's
Memoir which is like
I I helped him find he was looking for
like a good like inspiring story and it
was all over these like lists it was on
every single list
um he's like 25 through he loved it
and I was like do you support women in
literacy now and he said no he supports
men in literacy
okay at least he's consistent in the
fact that he doesn't want to see
literate women period no at least he's
consistent in the fact that he doesn't
support women period not even literate
women just women period period I'm glad
that he found a book that he likes
that's really a gorgeous update if we
could convince Ben to become a reader
like
and push the boundaries further than I
ever thought possible that would be we
can do anything we could do anything
speaking of reading new episode of the
redheads drop today lessons in chemistry
this episode was such a delight to
record because for the most part the
four of us are on the same page there's
in every single episode no matter how
good the book is there's always someone
but all the girls love this book and for
different reasons too I feel like there
were parts of each character that really
resonated with everyone obviously for
spinach it was 6 30 the dog who's just
like the best dog in the world
um it was such a good book it was such a
good episode so
please check it out the redheads book
club
oh my God
and then at the end of the episode we
all recap the other books that we read
this month I read five Dana red five I
think snitch red three and Becky red
were won so there's 14 book
recommendations in the episode if you're
looking for other things to read also
I'm kind of taking over the podcast
charts like not to make it a really big
deal
um and I'm just like guesting on all
these podcasts yes yesterday my episode
of straight up with stassi with stassi
dropped and it was so much fun to record
I recorded it like two weeks ago so I'll
see and I have so much in common not
only is she a toaster so all toasters
everywhere universally have so much in
common but like our interests are so
aligned it felt like we were just
getting coffee catching up and sharing
TV and book recommendations it was so
much fun to record and I'm like an OG
listener of straight up with sassy when
I used to work in Corporate America it
was the first and only podcast that I
listened to at the time and I adored it
so to be on it now if I could tell that
girl she'd be like go off Queen she
would be like that's my girl girl that's
my girl totally so check it out straight
up with sassy and then also I was on
Sophia with an F last week which the
episode is really making a lot of waves
I'm seeing a lot of Clips like on Tick
Tock I saw it too today it came up on my
fyp this morning fyp no way
yes well because I follow Sofia but
still okay you don't have to minimize it
but so interesting about guesting on
other people's podcasts are the things
that they want to talk to you about you
know like you see yourself one way but
it's interesting to hear how someone
else like what are the most interesting
Parts about you that they want to ask
you about or things that you've done
right it's also just like relaxing to
not have to think that too but it's like
when I Was preparing for these
interviews it's like I wonder what they
want to talk to me about like what do
they want to get my take on and they
probably want to talk to you about being
rolled's mom like for me that's the most
interesting part about you right now we
actually spoke about that on both
podcasts towards the ends of Sassy's
podcast we had a very just honest
conversation about postpartum things
weight loss Etc I think it's so
important to just like have those
conversations
on podcasts wherever because the thought
of having all those feelings of like not
being happy with where you are and also
feeling like you can't talk about it is
so shitty and I've actually seen over
the last few months some people being
like so disappointing to see you talking
about postpartum weight loss and it's
like I couldn't disagree more I think
people not having
I think everybody's going through it
privately so like why can't we talk
about it and just make ourselves feel a
little better knowing that other people
are feeling the exact same way and it
doesn't mean you need to go and lose all
the baby weight but you're allowed to
like not love with the way you yeah no
and also just the concept of somebody
like telling you what to talk about on
your podcast like go away go away I just
couldn't disagree more and I know that
if I wasn't a podcaster and I was going
through this it would you would
appreciate someone talking oh my God I
would appreciate it so much just the
honesty even if you're not gonna like
solve anything today like can we just
complain we that's kind of the ethos of
the morning toes We're not gonna solve
anything but we are gonna complain
and we're just going to talk about it
and now we've said it and now we've said
it thank you Jackie I couldn't agree
more so go check out your girl on all
these podcasts having such great combos
with such great women and I'm I'm
actually a woman who supports other
podcasting women woman woman yeah no I I
would agree with that yeah I think let's
support other podcasting women
um we've got a great show we've got
stories we've got Beverly Hills Season
Finale was on last night it was
infuriating real house has a Salt Lake
City episode two was on and it was also
infuriatingly boring
um so we're going to talk about that in
the TV recap it's Thursday it is also
our last episode of the week because
tomorrow I'm headed to Pittsburgh for my
show tickets available at girls no
job.com
tour good luck finding tickets and
Jackie is headed to Atlanta she's going
to be a little peachy girly her and Ben
are doing a meet and greet for spritz
Society in Atlanta at Total Wine so
check the Spritz Instagram for all the
details because Jack is going to be in
Atlanta for a day and you don't want to
miss it you don't want to miss it and I
would feel bad that there's no episode
tomorrow but today's episode is
literally going to be two hours plus as
stated there's an episode of the
redheads there's straight up with stassi
with Jackie out and there's Sophia with
an F with Jackie with an O So Jackie
with an O yes also I wanted to talk
about the content that I consumed
yesterday and I would love to hear what
got you through the day I had planned on
reading but then I had such a bad
migraine that I could not
I watched a few interesting things
caught up and tell me lies are you
caught up a new episode I am really good
episode but really infuriating like no
like wriggle what's his name Wrigley
Wrigley I need to kill him need to kill
him he's so [ __ ] annoying he's
so annoying but he's such like a lovable
no sweet no he's not no he wasn't like
maybe in the beginning but he's annoying
as [ __ ] now
um
and disrespecting someone's home that's
not gonna work for me no I know but you
know like at the end when he just like
Evan and Wrigley should actually be
friends they both have hearts it's
Stephen who's like ruining the group I I
can't even tell you how much I hate this
man I can't even tell you how much I
hate this man he's so creepy like he's
perfectly cast because he's [ __ ] evil
and I'm really feeling it in my core but
the silver lining of the episode was
Bree and Evan like finally getting
together and Bree finally having sex
with someone who like gives a shred of a
[ __ ] about her and it was glorious I was
so happy for her I was so happy for her
too I also watched the new docu-series
on Netflix
called Eat the Rich it's about the
GameStop situation that happened it's
three parts pretty fast moving I liked
it because I felt like at the time and I
feel like we said this all the time when
we were reporting on it like I didn't
fully understand everything that was
happening and how it happened and now
I've got it and it was just it was
really really interesting so I would I
would recommend it last night I saw it
when I was bruising for something to
watch on Netflix and instead of that I
chose The Bling Ring
um and I only watched two episodes and
I don't know if it's a story that like
we need to keep retelling especially
because it's pretty much a guide for how
to rob a celebrity's house like that guy
Nick who really like started the whole
ring with that girl Rachel
um he literally told you how to do it
like how to find the addresses go on
Google Maps search the terrain go up the
back they have all these fire escape
hikes in these gated communities so it
was like a little too in instructorial
you know like here's exactly how to do
it and
um everyone's stories are conflicting
with one another you know Nick is saying
Alexis you know wanted to be there so
bad she was totally sober she was ready
to go she's saying she was so [ __ ] up
on drugs she had no idea where she was
she doesn't remember a thing so it's
like we didn't get like a conclusive I
mean I didn't finish it but I don't
think we get a conclusive storyline
because they're both like lying on each
other
um but the way that the mom from pretty
wild is the star of the documentary
because like she's a full-blown liar and
like every time she says something they
cut to Alexis and Alexis's sister Gabby
like contradicting the mom entirely
oh wow it makes me feel weird that this
story is so glamorized and there was the
movie and everything because even as I
was watching last night Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills it's like in a few
years if we're getting like a movie and
a docu series and all this stuff about
the people who robbed Reed's house no
100 and I was actually glad they had
Audrina Patridge on there because the
whole time it was like glamorous
glamorous bags shoes cash Rolex and then
Audrina was like I was so [ __ ] afraid
for my life I locked myself in my closet
I called the police I never was able to
go back into that house again it still
freaks me out they had her interview be
done in the house that she was robbed in
like they were renting it and she was so
freaked out like and that's what the the
head of the LAPD was like burglary is
like not a victimless crime even if the
people are rich it's like first of all
Rachel Bilson they stole her mom's
engagement ring that she had on her like
first of all you lose such sentimental
things it's not just about the money
you're like invading someone's private
space like robbing the rich is not a
victimless crime just because you're
rich doesn't mean you don't have
feelings no and just like to disturb
someone's peace like that and cause
trauma that they probably will struggle
with for the rest of their lives like I
don't find that really interesting or
glamorous to be watching I agree they
were like making light of it maybe it
gets more serious I didn't really feel
like I needed to watch the whole thing
but I was oh and then they had Perez
Hilton on it and that's when I was like
I gotta go yeah these documentaries
always have the [ __ ] worst people
yeah have you no Scruples come on no
even the one I just watched it was who
was in it
I'll tell you later okay why I'll just
I'll tell you later okay
um and then I also oh I started blonde
oh
and I wanted to get into it because
she's really good in it she's amazing
she looks like her she sounds like her
and she's giving it her all I didn't
like the way the movie was
set up I didn't know like what year it
was ever we're flashing back we're going
forward it was so weird and that it's
like a psychological Thriller right yeah
I didn't like how the like the director
that's whoever that is is not my kind of
director I wanted to know more about
Marilyn I feel like I don't know
anything about her but she's such she's
like this iconic huge iconic figure in
everybody's life in the forever in
history I saw a clip on Tick Tock from
the movie of like the baby in her womb
like talking to her begging her not to
get an abortion that didn't happen
well I mean I got to the part I already
watched the part where she gets an
abortion and I didn't go further but
they're showing the baby in the womb but
it didn't talk oh okay like in the scene
that I saw the baby was like please
don't do what you did last time oh okay
so then that's further along yeah and I
was like that is a unique POV I was just
I was shocked because I thought it was
like this glamorous Maryland movie and
that's what I realized it's not like
other movies yeah but she's amazing and
I wanted to know more about Marilyn but
I'm not going to turn it back on yeah I
feel that I wish it was just like a
director who just goes a story from Like
A to Z yeah yeah I love an A to Z moment
I think that directors are getting like
really creative going beyond the A to Z
structure like they're going you know B
to f z to Y right but you know I like to
Q you know what I could do I could do L
to A to Z
you know of course see that's putting a
little spin on a traditional structure a
to z b to f l to y z to a is not working
here no this is literally that scene
from friends like two four a four six
two a five six seven seven seven seven
seven
and I caught up on Southern Charm
great but it was the season finale I
don't really have anything to say I'll
catch you at the reunion Q should we
Dive In
yes I think without further Ado we
should dive into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you realize
how much you love the show the toast
okay stuff every day no for sure on
Tuesday's episode people did like mine
like less is more when it comes to the
change I agree with that and maybe
that's where I'll land just give me I
just would like to improv and try a few
different things I feel like this is a
time of experimentation and with your
blessing I would I would like to do that
obviously the one I just said is not it
I think we can rule that out for sure
but I'd like to try some stuff okay well
today's uh experimental episode is
brought to you by ZocDoc a free app that
shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance and are
available when you need them we use
octoc you should too I'm always having
mysterious ailments you know and I'm
like oh I need to go see an allergist oh
this rash I need to go see a
dermatologist and it could be really
hard to just find like a trusted Doctor
Who takes your insurance especially if
you just moved it's really difficult to
get good recommendations but on ZocDoc
you can find every specialist Under the
Sun whether you're trying to straighten
your teeth fix an achy back get a mole
checked out or removed ZocDoc has you
covered
by the way just side note I got a
message from a girl this week who was
like I have debated getting this mole on
my face removed like four years and like
you inspired me to do it and I because I
was always nervous it was kind of Scar
um then I saw you and I did it and it
was the best decision I ever made so I'm
just like changing lives changing lives
literally zocdocs mobile app is as easy
as ordering a ride to a restaurant
getting delivery to your house you
search fine and book doctors with just a
few Taps find and review local doctors
where you can read patient verified
reviews from real people who made real
appointments so now when you walk into
your doctor's office you are set to see
someone in your network who gets you go
to zocdoc.com to find the right doctor
that's right for you book an appointment
in person or even remotely and that'll
work for your schedule every month
millions of people use ZocDoc we are two
of them it is our go-to whenever we need
to find and book a quality doctor also
for me when I travel is probably when I
get the most mysterious ailments and
being on tour and just like a fabulous
girl who's always you know traveling
um it's hard to get health care when
you're in a different state and ZocDoc
is super helpful for that especially
when you move like I need to I've been
on doc doc I need a dentist right oh
these teeth are hurting go to zocdoc.com
toast and download the ZocDoc app for
free then start your search for a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours ZocDoc
expelled
zocdoc.com toast zocdoc.com toast
thank you mclartia you're welcome and
you know who's one of the highest rated
doctors on ZocDoc doctor for chairman
doctor for chairman the worker and
actually you know who beat him out this
year for the highest rated doctor on
Sock Doc ew Dr nazarden
of course I mean that's always going to
be
The Benchmark who Theo and it's
important to have people to look up to
role models you have goals and if only
Theo one day
100 and he's so funny along the way I
[ __ ] love not Dr nazarden we should
try and get him on the toes those are
the interviews I'm interested in
conducting 100 percent
our first story is hurts my heart to say
because I feel like I've been living in
a state of denial about this one Tom
Brady hires a divorce lawyer after
Giselle retains her own after wife
Giselle bun chin retain a divorce lawyer
Tom Brady enlisted one for himself a
source confirms to people on Tuesday
people reported that Giselle hired a
divorce attorney amid their marriage
troubles and Brady her husband of 13
years was quote trying to figure out
what to do page six was the first to
report the news the couple who shared
two children along with Brady son John
Edward with his ex Bridget Moynihan have
been dealing with quote a lot of tension
in the marriage in part because of
Brady's decision to return to the NFL
this season after a brief retirement a
source previously previously told people
she was so happy when he announced his
retirement
and obviously now is frustrated that
he's back in the game
yeah so I feel like this is you know
very much like a confirmation and that
doesn't mean that two people can't
reconcile amidst divorce proceedings but
I'm just going to move forward with the
mentality that these two are no longer
together and while that is extremely sad
it's devastating
it's heartbreaking
um it is fun to imagine to single people
out of Tom Brady and Gisele I mean the
internet is Ablaze being like Giselle
and Pete Davidson which yeah which I
totally could see like a little fling
also girl boss Town had a great
prediction that like Kim and Tom Brady
like will go on a date like maybe not
OTP but like they might go on a date
that's gorgeous okay I mean it's
stunning so that works for Tom he's
settled there's no one else on the list
that I I feel like he has to be with
except that Kim she's on the list yeah
and so for Giselle
um it could be Jason Momoa
oh my God it's Jason Momoa even though I
don't know if he should be on the list
he was spotted out again without uh but
she's also still on the list and I feel
like when once we take them off that
will be a big day but we need more
confirmation not just like they were at
the same place okay also I feel like if
we think it's not gonna happen then it
will happen so it's good if we keep
pretending like it won't no like I'm so
shipping just um Jason Momo and Asia
Gonzalez but knowing that giselle's now
on the market I'm kind of like hoping
that the ship sinks yeah I'm
self-sabotaging My Own ship Gisele and
Josh Groban
yeah Giselle and Keenan
oh that's cute well let's think of
giselle's type because she dated Leo and
then she dated Tom Brady so she loves
like an All-American sweetheart like she
does Boy Next Door Brad Pitt pit
de la Brad
Brad
even though he's been spotted with
emrata they're not giving us enough and
I'm not here for it oh I am but like
he's still in the in the game to me he's
on the market still so I'm Gonna Keep
theorizing I'm not here for it you're
not
why I'm just not
okay not every ship is for every sailor
right beautifully said
truly stunning this is sad I feel like
this divorce is like gonna be kind of
lengthy and messy because they've been
married for so many years and they have
so many assets like between him and her
um
and I know celebrities even like
they always keep their [ __ ] clean but
like this was a real marriage like a
real family a real institution I agree I
feel like they were so in love and so
when that love goes south it really
turns into like hey Cyril hate and
that's when things get messy you know I
know I know I'm nervous I'm really
nervous this is giving like PTSD from
you know Children of Divorce I feel like
this is going to be huge yeah I hope
it's not
contention part amicably
for the sake of everyone
right and you think like when you have
so much money like you know all right
you take this house right but it's not
like no matter how much money you have
like divorce there's so much like hatred
and anger and jealousy like even if you
have a lot of assets or not a lot of
assets like it's the same hatred but and
I feel like it becomes less about the
assets and more about just control to
the other person yeah yeah totally yeah
wishing them the best truly hopefully
you know who's probably you know having
a great day is Bridget Moynihan yeah
because Tom bounced on her for Giselle
and also like took the kid with them
half the time so I'm sure she's having
it's a great day to be Bridget Moynihan
and I don't think I would say that for
every day because for a while she was
like the loser of this group like and
she's always Tom Brady's ex like she has
and she's on a hit show
she's done two she's done two iconic
shows she's obviously Aaron on Blue
Bloods she's Natasha on Sex in the City
she's had an illustrious career but like
what oh you want to hear something so
crazy always
I don't know if I've ever told this
story and like maybe I won't get
invented back now but like I haven't
been invited back since so I was invited
to
um like watch a taping of Blue Bloods
when they were filming their family
scene which is like really the only
scenes that all the cast is in because
is Thrice there today no I just heard a
bark
maybe it was Bruno no he's not here no
Theo's not here are you lying to me did
anyone else hear that no I swear to God
maybe it was a phantom bark I hear
Phantom ever I hear Phantom cries now I
hear Phantom sirens
okay but so sorry to disturb you I went
to a family dinner scene and I was like
sitting in those director's chairs with
the headphones on like watching them do
the takes and in between takes like the
cast was just chatting and the cast is
filled with like normal [ __ ] people
it's not even though Tom Selleck is
there like they're all just normal they
talk he was talking about his horse farm
he has an avocado Farm in Malibu and
someone was talking about how they're
seeing a guy who lives in Boston and
Bridget Moynihan was like oh I used to
see a guy who lives in Boston
when he was on the Patriots and it was
like silent for a second and then
everyone laughed and so she was like
being funny about it so I actually ended
up like having a lot of respect for her
just from that interaction
um but I do think it's a good day to be
her yeah and as far as being invited
back to the set I don't feel like that's
a recurring like how many times do you
want to go to the set oh I'd like to go
every day
um to work there and I'd like to be the
star if we're just requesting things
what would your role be if you were on
the show that's so funny I was talking
to my good friend
um
wait why can't you remember his name I
was talking to my good friend Donnie
Wahlberg um the last time I was on set
there he was like you should come be an
extra and I'm like please like set it up
I can't do that you can
um and he was like well what would you
like want to do and I was like that's a
good question I think I would be like a
D.A from you know like a like
like Staten Island or something like
from a different district and I would
come because we'd need to like work on
this there's a serial killer who like
started in Staten Island now the feds
are bringing in the New York City
Borough and we're all working together
and at first it's contentious because
it's like you know this is my
jurisdiction no this is your first
version of this case for so long and
it's deeply personal to me but sometimes
when you're in a case like that and I'm
a D.A so I know this like when you're so
in it it almost blurs your vision
because you become so attached to it you
have like horse blinders on yeah um so
Donnie Wahlberg would help me see out of
that and ultimately we'd catch the
killer together and become a huge Heroes
on the cover of every newspaper
um and that's just an idea and if it
does well you know maybe every couple of
years there's another Staten Island
crossover you know no and I see that you
haven't given this a lot of thought no
no none whatsoever it does not keep me
up she doesn't lay awake at night no
dreaming of the Staten Island killer no
never never me no uh not sure how we got
here here but I do think it's time to
move on to the next story we got here
from Bridget Moynihan because she is the
Bridge to Terabithia she is the Bridget
that's the name of today's episode
Bridget to Terabithia
our next story Fat Joe says he won't
change his name even though he's no
longer fat
legendary rapper Fat Joe has lost a ton
of weight over the past decade but he
says he's definitely definitely not
losing fat from his name quote as a
business I spend so many millions and
millions of dollars that joke that it
wouldn't be smart to change my name now
he told paychecks of the five-year
celebration of um it's a 10 Hair Care he
said he won the name at the costume of
some pretty serious teasing he said I
grew up in the projects where there was
no filter when the teacher would say
write something on the chalkboard I was
always big so the crack of my butt would
show so the girls would be like Joey
crack and that's how I kept my name
so but your name is Fat Joe not Joey
Grace well maybe it evolved over the
years wait I'm gonna cry like literally
nobody talks about like the trauma of
being fat when you're young like kids
are so mean and I love Fat Joe and I
think it's important to mention but it's
also I I love like turning your trauma
into your success disgrace Queen right
literally like being inspired by
something bad that happened to you and
having the last laugh and you know
reputation uh What's the phrase why
can't it like running to the bank
laughing all the way to the bank
I agree I love taking like your hardest
moment and like making it into your like
greatest achievement I reputation
reputation the snakes like she really
did get the last laugh on that
so I don't think you should change it
also just from like a business and
marketing standpoint Like Fat Joe is
Iconic and I don't really feel and I
think if you've struggled with your
weight you're gonna agree with this
sentiment like being fat is not a
physical state it is a state of mind
once you've been fat like you are fat in
your brain forever like that [ __ ] sticks
with you you are who you are because at
one point in your life you either were
or currently are fat it changes who you
are as a person so I feel like you know
you can be fat without being physically
big do you know what I mean 100 okay
okay I so when I saw this I was like it
never even occurred to me for him to
change his name
and I don't think that he should no I
don't think that he should either though
I do love a Rebrand love love love I
don't think it's necessary in this case
no me neither in this case I rule
nobread necessary no Rebrand especially
you spend millions and millions of
dollars on marketing we hadn't spent
Millions on marketing no totally and
like you know he really came alive in
the age of CDs and like records so there
are these ever you know I'm sure a lot
of Big Fat Joe fans have like tons of
his CDs and then they become irrelevant
physical touch points well no I mean and
I was actually thinking about this with
our merch because people are like well
what about all the merchant like now to
me it's a vintage iconic One of a Kind
never to be seen again merch no it's
true and we do have one more merch
collection that will feature some
morning elements yeah and it's the final
one so I just and it makes me I love our
merch it makes me love it even more so
like this was a moment in time and you
were either there for it where you were
in
the girls I gotta get it and the girls
that don't don't they do not are you
ready for our next story mm-hmm
so Daily Mail has an exclusive that the
survivors of the 1994 killing that's now
the subject of Kim Kardashian's Spotify
podcast are saying that no one contacted
them and insists the man she's trying to
free is guilty because they saw him do
it so a brother and sister who survived
the 1994 triple murder that is now the
subject of Kim Kardashian's true crime
podcast on Spotify tell Daily Mail the
star never bothered to contact them to
check the facts of the case and insist
the man she's trying to free is in fact
guilty Kevin yikes yeah Kevin Keith was
convicted of murdering his ex-girlfriend
marichel Chapman her four-year-old
daughter Marche and marichel's Aunt
Linda Chapman at their home in Ohio in
1994. he has been in prison for 28 years
but insists he's innocent Kim believes
him and has used his story as the launch
pad for her Spotify podcast the system
which just launched this week we were
just talking about it but two people who
survived the shooting and witnessed it
say he's guilty they are quinita and
Quentin Reeves marichel's cousins who
were six and four at the time now in
their early 30s the siblings tell
dailymail.com they were stunned when the
podcast emerged on October 3rd without
their contribution they claimed they
were never invited on as guests and that
they've never even heard from the
crusading Kardashian they said she did
not contact us not one time if Kim wants
to get involved she should come and meet
us face to face Quentin said who is now
a father of two the siblings who were
both shot in the stomach by the murderer
remain adamant that Keith is the killer
they say they knew him because he was
friends with their father and that they
remember seeing him point the gun at
their relatives we saw it with our own
eyes you don't forget something like
that I don't care what Kim Kardashian
says Kevin did it Quentin said I mean I
think wherever you fall on this case
whether you believe this man is innocent
or guilty I think we can all agree like
if there's witnesses to the crime and
Kim doesn't
include them on the podcast like
that's kind of like low-key like wrong
no yeah I mean I think they might also
be germane to the story right people who
are actually there sources close to the
podcast claim that the siblings were
contacted but they maintained that they
were not oh
so this is a game if he said she said
yeah but if there are I mean I guess if
they contacted them and they didn't
respond
um what can you do but I just yeah I
know you by the way they don't have a
Kim doesn't have a responsibility to
have them on but she has a
responsibility to reach out
yes definitely and for the sake of the
podcast they can decide what they want
to do yeah oh this is touchy I just said
the first time she heard from the team
was on Monday October 3rd the day the
podcast went live and that it was a
heads up from the producer that doesn't
count no no no that doesn't count no
this is uh
a very weird situation I do feel like
Kim will have to address it yeah and a
lot some of the reasons why Kim believes
that this man is innocent is because I
guess after the shooting
um the siblings initially identified
someone named Bruce as the person who
did it but they said that they were um
obviously in a haze post shooting right
sometimes got those people the Keith and
Bruce confused they were their dad's
friends
um well that does muddy the waters quite
a bit
um also
being four and six it's just like a
difficult spot for witness you know
like four-year-olds and six-year-olds
are just like kids yeah
so like sticky I don't even know what to
say like yikes yikes are wishing
everyone the best but even if if Kim
believes he's innocent like on this
podcast she should paint the whole
picture which is like oh for sure there
are people
maintain that it was him no for the sake
of the podcast getting the full picture
I would be tuning into this podcast to
learn everything there is to know about
this case and obviously the two
witnesses is a huge part of that so to
leave it out ain't right yeah that's
totally fair
drama we'll see what happens with it
right but a little more legal news
is granted bail if she can find a place
to stay in America I thought she was
getting deported she could be released
from the ice detention center but only
if the convicted fraudster can find a
place to stay page six has learned Anna
you can stay with me but you just have
to come on the toast like once a week
on Wednesday the U.S immigration judge
uh granted her ten thousand dollars Bond
but she needs to provide a residential
address where she will be under 24-hour
confinement for the duration of her
immigration proceedings I don't think
that would work for you because you like
to be alone yeah no 24 hours get the
[ __ ] out of here trying to restart her
members only club and art dealings in
your house you know I think it's
important that we talk about that the
building in which you do need to talk
about this the building in which
was obsessed with 281 park it has been
fully built out into a museum and I
believe it's a members Club someone just
invited me there to go to dinner and I
was like wait why do I know this address
and I couldn't make the dinner I was so
upset but I do plan on going
um it's this very exclusive restaurant
Museum experience it's called like the
Veronica or something and Anna wasn't
wrong about that let's just say no they
kind of like took her idea made it the
reality it's literally an artist
Collective literally no she was not
wrong no
and what are the odds that it's in the
same building I feel like they kind of
stole her idea they should have to pay
her royalties well that's the thing
about Anna it's like she wasn't
completely untalented like she was just
a scheming fraudster Cod woman but she
had some good ideas The Talented Mrs
Ripley right also the judge ruled that
she cannot post on her social media
either directly or by a third party
well maybe she'll stay with the girl
what was the girl's name Rachel
no no from the hotel
why would that girl have her stay with
her are they because at in the end it
really seemed like that girl was
obsessed with Anna
I know
not Rachel even though Rachel when I was
watching The Bling Ring Thing
the girl who started the robberies and
who was like kind of like the brains
behind it was this girl Rachel who
wasn't a part of the documentary and she
reminded me so much of Rachel from Anna
delvey just because like she was the
girl and her name was Rachel
it's just such like a like a standard
name you know what I mean yeah so you
would think like The Mastermind behind
this big Bling Ring would be like a
Svetlana you know not a Rachel
you know I went to I went to high school
with Rachel
what's that saying
arose By Any Other Name
is still a rose
yeah that's a phrase I think what
they're trying to say is it doesn't
matter what your name is like you're
either a wench or you're not you're
either a rose or a thorn or a wedge or a
wench you're a rose spelled w-r
no sorry that's not a funny joke
continue let's move on to our fifth and
final story that will lead into our TV
recap
um okay but I just want to let you know
I texted you a story if you are feeling
passionate about this final one Olivia
texted it to us I'm not feeling
passionate about this final one because
it's we could talk about it in the TV
recap oh it's here okay yeah I thought
this was such an interesting story we
didn't have the article Business Insider
premium it's behind a paywall but we got
the PDF so Olivia has a here it is and
it's fascinating stuff it is
patreon's deal with top tick tockers
fell far short of expectations leaked
documents show here's what it means for
the company's Creator strategy coming
off its layoffs oh I didn't um you know
they were doing layoffs but leaked
documents suggest patreon's 1 million
dollar deals with tick tockers Larry and
little honey
I pardon me and Lil Huddy fell short of
expectations company insiders also said
patreon was in talks with Mr Beast but a
deal was never reached inside insight
into the deals comes a mid-company-wide
layoffs that impacted the Creator
Partnerships team so this report came
out by the way and everyone was quaking
over the fact that Mr Beast almost did a
deal with patreon like sure that's
interesting the other part about Lil
Hootie and larae for me is like so much
more interesting yes tell them what
happened uh well can you read it from
the article because I don't know the
figures exactly but I know that patreon
paid them one million dollars one
million dollars each
yeah I believe so to join the platform
and for one Million Dollar Deals plural
for those who don't know patreon is kind
of like an only fans it's a platform
where creators go and release content
but it's all behind a paywall so you do
like monthly subscriptions we have one
patreon.com the toast we finally got our
new link patreon.com the toast can't
stress that enough
um so here are the details of their
partnership
it's kind of patrons like only fans but
uh it's a lot of podcasting but the
creators that gravitate towards it are
different but it's yes a subscription
for based content yeah comedy Creator
Laray launched in December his patreon
page where he hosts a platform exclusive
talk show called the hot seat in January
e-boy and musician Chase Lil Huddy
Hudson onboarded both creators are
massive draws on Tick Tock with 26.3
million and 32.2 million followers
respectively the total value for their
patreon deals was 1.325 million dollars
a piece according to slides these
presentation obtained by Insider so
patreon played these two really big tick
tockers to come to the platform and do
exclusive content over there and
hopefully grow overall patreon audience
um according to the presentation the
company expected larae would drive a
hundred thousand dollars in
subscriptions in his first month on the
platform but he brought in just 2217 in
total membership volume which refers to
Total payments from fans two thousand
dollars Lil honey brought in 2 670 far
less than the twenty five thousand
dollars patreon expected for his first
month and I just find this so
interesting one because just like the
landscape of social media it's so crazy
how you can have 30 million followers
and not get more than a thousand people
to watch your talk show
and it's also just this like really
interesting conversation about like
followers verse fans and followers
versus like a community and if you would
have asked me how much money I thought
larae and Lil Hootie would bring on
patreon like I could have told you this
by the way like not every not every
Creator no matter how many followers you
have is built for this type of model and
it's not even about how many followers
you have it's about what type of
followers you have like patreon would
have been better off spending a million
dollars on like five much smaller
creators who have like super engaged
audiences and more Niche like moms like
real communities as opposed to just like
people with tons of followers and I feel
like this was a huge waste of money
clearly and obviously I don't think they
spent the 2.6 million dollars to get
back the 2.6 million dollars they
obviously wanted to make a dent in the
2.6 but it's marketing money and every
dollar you spend on marketing you're not
gonna get back but I don't think they
thought it was going to be 2.6 million
dollars twenty six hundred dollars in
returns right but at the end of the day
the marketing money that you spend
eventually brings in more money
otherwise you're constantly you're well
that's the goal yes so I don't think
they expected it to be tomorrow but to
build up
to getting those numbers back and I do
think it's crazy and it really shows you
like there you could have a big audience
um but are they an Engaged audience or
are they a passive audience
and also like patreon is really it is
podcast specific like it's very comedy
focused it's a lot of True Crime I
imagine this was them trying to expand
to a new category of
almost like
subscription model for YouTube pretty
much you know yeah yeah yeah yeah this
was just such a Miss I'm like I was
shocked by these numbers I saw Tick Tock
going around and this girl was like they
literally paid these kids over a million
dollars and they brought in two grand
always so fascinating like remember a
while ago that influencer who had like
millions of followers she like put out a
T-shirt and no one bought it and she was
like right she did a meet and greet at
VidCon
we might be talking about two different
people oh this girl had tons of
followers enough to get invited to
VidCon to host a meet and greet and not
one person showed up that's a different
person this was a person who like put
out a t-shirt
um like merch and no one bought her
t-shirt and she was like so upset like
why do you guys buy my merch and she
like I think she sold like 20 shirts I
mean well that attitude is beyond
entitled like why don't you guys buy my
shirt who the [ __ ] are you right but
like she has millions of followers but
they're not people who want to actually
buy stuff from her no like the
intersection of followers versus like
having transaction ability and like an
audience who actually wants to listen to
your podcast by your book see you on
tour do all these things is they're not
mutually exclusive like just because you
have followers doesn't mean any of them
give a shred of a [ __ ] about what you
have to offer yeah and that's why when
like people just get in this game and
like rack up followers for the sake of
having followers thinking it's going to
create all these other opportunities for
them when it doesn't it's like yikes
yeah but I do think that Brands clearly
are a little bit behind on yeah
followers
and they're like
ah no but brands are also I actually
thought about this a lot recently
because somebody was telling me about an
influencer that they worked with who
um
had like totally fraudulent followers
um and I think it's really interesting
like don't you feel like that should be
like a felony
because you're accepting let's say all
three million of my followers were fake
they're not but let's say for argument's
sake that they were and I accepted a fee
from McDonald's
based on the belief that I had three
million followers that they wanted to
engage with like are isn't that
nefarious
yeah that is and I I've heard so far as
people going to doctor their analytics
because when you do a campaign with a
brand you then have to send them
analytics here's how many millions of
people were reached and they put
together a deck the agency puts it
together for the brand so I've heard of
people even going so far as doctoring
their own analytics like on Photoshop to
substantiate the claim that they had
real followers to begin with I don't
know that that's a felony but McDonald's
should be able to sue you once they
discover that and I I think that's kind
of similar to companies who fudge their
numbers and pretend to be more
successful that they are I don't think
that the law yet has caught up with the
internet but that is really interesting
especially budging analytics but what's
crazy is like if you like tell a lie in
the mail it's wire fraud right right and
like who the [ __ ] is using mail
you could doctor your analytics like
that no that's such a good call not the
wire fraud mail fraud mail fraud and
email lie is wireframe
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's so funny yeah
uh so those are the past five stories I
feel as though you needed to know them
before we get into our TV recap 100 you
needed to know them we've got Beverly
Hills season finale recap coming at you
and it's brought to you by
better help I'm going to need someone to
talk to after this most recent season of
Beverly Hills it can be tough to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode when faced with a challenge in life
but when you learn how to find your own
Solutions there's no better feeling a
therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver making it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter what so
whatever it is that inspired you to
start therapy whether it's you going
through a difficult time a friend of
yours recommended better help whatever
the reason is you can expect results you
know better help is going to match you
with people who are going to give you
the tools to work through whatever it is
that you're working through in life if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely done online you'll get matched
with a therapist after filling out a
brief survey and the best part is that
you can switch therapists anytime if you
have ever done therapy you know that
more often than not the first person you
match with might not be the best person
for you and that doesn't mean that that
person is a bad therapist it just means
that you two aren't jiving and a really
kind of frustrating part about in-person
therapy is like jumping around from
different therapists getting new
recommendations better help makes it
really easy to switch it's not awkward
or anything it's fabulous so when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can help get you there visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash toast okay Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills just my
first question for you on the episode
was this gorgeous event Kyle held um
that I don't feel like at any point they
really told what the charity was right
that's so true what is Princess Monica
charity let's look it up
she was like it's going to help our
artists and all of our charitable
Endeavors like it sounded like Anna
delvey yeah that sounding like
fraudulent philanthropy it feels
sounding like a documentary we're going
to read about in a few years it supports
emerging performers in theater dance and
film in the form of awards Grand
scholarships and fellowships oh that's
nice that is nice to help students it
was a really classy Affair between the
diamonds and the it was and it was
wonderful to see the women at an event
that other people were at too because
yeah usually they would get all dressed
up Black Tie diamonds Etc just to like
sit around and talk to each other but
the fact that there was other people
there were things happening that's what
we used to get from Real Housewives like
there were events and then the women
showed up to them now they just
manufacture stuff and everyone gets so
dressed up to the nines and it's just
like so silly and just like a waste of
Glam but before that party I thought
that garcelle's bubbles and birkin's
party looked so much fun everyone was
like actually having a good time yeah
and I needed a Birkin like I was
literally so jealous that little like
setup the guy had it was what a fabulous
way to shop totally was there one that
caught your eye in particular I mean
honestly the green one that Sutton and
Kyle were fighting over like was
sickening and did any of them even buy a
bag except for garcelle Sutton bought
that taupe clutch which was kind of ugly
um and I don't know if anyone else
bought anything yeah no but it was a fun
afternoon and the women were in good
spirits it was stunning I just love
garcelle and I also love Cherie like we
need to know Cherie a little bit more
they've really given her nothing and
she's still like super funny and
interesting in the small things that she
gets like I would like to know more
about Cherry yeah maybe next season
she'll come on uh because I think a lot
of people probably like her yeah what I
love about garcelle is I feel like when
we're watching the show it's so easy to
see what's right and what's wrong and
like what's happening because we have
like this zoomed out View and
I'm so like I admire so much that in
every moment in every situation like
garcelle can see exactly what's
happening and it's as if like she has
that perch in that perspective but she
doesn't because sometimes in the moment
you don't it's hard to tell what's right
what's right like you don't see the
other conversations that are happening
you don't know what's going on so it's
hard to be right when you don't have all
the information totally she Nails it
every single time no you're so right
she's so wise and mature and I just
[ __ ] love this woman and honestly I
don't know what we would do if she
wasn't on this show because that group
that ran this show for the last couple
of years Erica Rena darite Kyle it's not
cutting it for me anymore and I thought
it was really interesting that Kyle
chose to
um confide in garcelle at that event
because I think she sees garcelle as the
only one who's seeing this clearly like
dorit is so desperate to stay in the
middle she's like not gonna take any
stand Erica and Lisa are like coming for
Kyle and her sister and so she sought
refuge in the only rational person in
this group and I thought that was so
wise of her and I know a lot of people
are like well why is it on Lisa and
Erica to stop the fight with Kathy like
it should be on Kathy to stop the fight
with Kathy and I just don't agree with
that like I don't no especially because
Lisa and especially Lisa is saying like
I'm bringing this up because I'm
defending you and I'm protecting you and
so Kyle is saying if you want to defend
me and want to protect me what I need
you to do is for is move on she
apologized like and you need to accept
that and move on but
Lisa can't do that because at the end of
the day that's she's not trying to
protect and defend her no she's trying
to embarrass Kathy because that she's
jealous good for everyone no and this
thing where Lisa keeps saying that Kyle
I mean excuse me that Kathy needs help
because of her behavior I'm sure but
Kathy was acting wild uh have you seen
this show I mean literally the day
before Erica was being insane uh hello
Amsterdam Lisa Rinna everyone has had
this psychotic moment what about Lisa
across the table at dorit's home oh it's
not Toothless Gala yeah like a complete
breakdown breakdown and then
taking it all back and being like I'm
sorry I'm in a really bad place like
what about what about all that that's
literally what Kathy then said yeah that
had a breakdown and then came to Kyle's
house and said I'm sorry and I'm in a
bad place the cat needs help and you
don't no Lisa Rinna is so awful and you
know what it felt like the the episode
was ending abruptly when Lisa and Erica
were leaving and I was actually glad
Sutton brought them back in because it's
like we're all talking about this and
we're talking about you so just get in
here and defend yourselves like
a hundred percent do I think Lisa and
Eric had something to do with it leaking
100
I oh I'm sorry Kyle with the read to
filth when she was like I'm pretty sure
you know Hilton is a better last name
right now than Girardi
that was so good yeah the only thing
that I thought was a good point was that
if Erica and Nikki share a publicist why
would publicist weekly yes but I'm sure
there's other ways and other people who
knows that's a great call that was by
that was made by Erica and I do have to
say I feel like I've been hard on Kyle
these last couple episodes like she did
do the right thing last night like she
is moving away from the people who are
making it hard for her sister like she
is being in this moment a good sister
yeah but I think there's tickets back
Kathy and Kyle yeah did you see the
pictures that came out from the reunion
it was each woman on their own they
never got a group shot it was apparently
like so horrible now I could see how the
reading goes so South because I think
that for Kyle Renna and Erica I don't
know how they can come back from this
quickly I think eventually it'll all be
fine but I think the wounds are still
fresh
and that throws a huge wrench into the
group dynamic which is like the five and
the five who have been like so exclusive
and not inclusive of like the new girls
garcelle Sutton uh Crystal it's
it's awkward like as [ __ ] yeah I just
don't love it as new girls gonna say was
Kris Jenner commented on Kathy's picture
from the reunion a bunch of Hearts which
is just so funny because she's beefing
with Lisa Rena because Lisa was like you
know taking up for 818 and Chris has
spoken and taking Kathy's side no it's
like Lisa Rinna is so desperate her
showing up in that Balenciaga outfit
that Kim literally wore exactly like
it's really losery but Kathy's the one
who's jealous of the Kardashians right
right right right
right
um honestly I don't even think Lisa
Rinna is jealous of the Kardashians if
anything she's jealous of the Foster
hadids because she tried desperately to
do what Yolanda did with her daughters
yeah and it didn't work out in the same
way
no Miss Amelia Gray is having like a
major fashion moment she's kind of like
an IT girl of fashion right now yeah she
is and it happened like so
randomly
good for her yeah
um and then Real Housewives of Salt Lake
City episode two it was horrible like
literally horrible I hate the show I
only watch half because my TV was
crapping out and I thought you missed
nothing a cue to go to sleep
um there was a shaman everyone cried one
person stormed out and the next week no
one's even gonna care uh about the
person they're fighting with now because
they'll be fighting with someone else it
was so bad that is bad I didn't get to
when they went on the trip I saw Jen
crying with her mom and it's like
no I can't help but think about her mom
literally liquidating her entire life
savings and teacher's pension a million
dollars to give to her daughter who
stole money for only for Jen to then
plead guilty so right all of that right
will work
was for what I don't know but I did feel
I can't believe I felt for Jen a little
bit in that moment because of her kids
um and and that's why I'm like
frustrated that I'm watching this
because it's like
why am I feeling bad for someone who
took advantage of such vulnerable people
because we're only seeing one side of it
like we're not seeing but you know who I
was like really actually getting annoyed
with this episode was Miss Heather k
um because like I get that she's like
the kind of Class Clown she's like I was
making the joke but
like they have this Shaman come and I
think shamans I'm not even like into
that sort of stuff but everyone was like
taking it seriously and like having a
moment and like she just like was make
making fun of it the whole time and it's
like everyone is getting into it like
just get into it and shut up like we
always have to be making fun of
everything read the room read the room
like stop
okay that's cool that they were into it
yeah
um but I don't really have many other
thoughts on Salt Lake City it wasn't a
particularly good episode
uh no no it was not then Meredith was
talking to Whitney like Meredith is
talking so much trash about Lisa that
she's doing the exact same thing that
Lisa did to her which is undermining
like her position
but can I say one thing that when they
got to this house in Arizona which was
so ugly and disgusting I was shocked
someone walked in and was like is this
one of Mary Cosby's rentals like it was
like old big couches like it was so
weird
um
I know Meredith is like not acting right
but like
she comes late to the shaman thing and
she's like I'm sorry I'm late I was
having like such bad anxiety honestly
about being here with you guys because
the last time we were all on a trip like
my father had just died and not only
that but like literally his death was
weaponized against me and now we're back
here almost a year later it's almost the
anniversary and I'm honestly just like
I'm shook so I can excuse her behavior a
little bit because I actually forgot how
[ __ ] evil everyone was to her last
year yeah given what she was going
through even beyond that so you know
what I'm gonna allow it okay I like that
perspective and it's hard to remember
what happened last season because like
every episode was different and every
Alliance is different and I actually
can't keep up but I appreciate that
um but the episode is not over yet if
you're listening as a podcast please
enjoy our episode
our interview with Jessica Knoll author
screenwriter executive producer she's
amazing and she was so funny
um and if you want to watch it on
YouTube just head over to our YouTube
channel and the video is up already so
thank you so much for listening to the
toast Millennium show where we deliver
the past five stories that need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast and our podcast can
be found so that Spotify iTunes Stitch
your public radio I already castbox all
the places where we listen to podcast
find us more details leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
increase but Thursday this is our final
episode of the week so we will see you
back in studio on Tuesday because Monday
is Columbus Day better known as
indigenous people's day and there's no
toast so we'll see you there wait that's
this Monday yeah oh see you Tuesday guys
I think there's so many podcast episodes
for you to enjoy that I am on